okay four people joining this livestream
we are looking at database connectivity
and more from language we are we hope
the very late stages of the version 12
cycle working on what's going in there
okay let's start off talking about the
way let's see where was the example put
the examples that we were looking at
last time
what are the examples we're looking at
last time which is in your Dropbox what
was it called
dear Moyes the folder I okay okay so
here um and all that's unnecessary now
right so the issue here we were talking
about before was the how to do the
wrapping of database inspect and so on
so did you guys come up with a solution
yes so I have already updated the
relevant tuition pages I removed the
business back mm-hmm and since we
already have sorry I basically copied
what we were already doing with at least
or so in Auntie story you can decide to
construct an entity store that doesn't
have all the so I it's the there is a
usage message which is the third I added
so if you want to just have an entity
source with three types you can just
give the list of those types and then a
little bits back and so so basically now
you can just say but first of all you
can't I don't we we probably want to
mirror this one here this T spec form at
the T spec no that's just a string it's
not the spec okay so I added that if you
scroll below there I added a bunch of
tentative details below because the to
document the the database back spec spec
of this okay
so so if you look at the
that's right under your mouth now that's
the thing I copied for relational
database object so if you want to just
inspect a few tables and you can say
just table 1 table 2 table 3 ok so let
me just understand so we've got database
connection and then the idea is we have
a single wrapper relational database
object that wraps around the database
connection right Yan has certain
properties is that correct
it doesn't wrap so a relational database
object when you wrap it around the base
connection connects to the connection
and fills in the first argument of
relational database object below the
schema information so it's it's own
constructor it's not just a wrapper
okay now the analogy here
okay so then I just want to understand
if we look at the analogy with other
database setups here do we want to call
it relational database object or just
relational database or relation yeah I
mean
I think it's good to call it an object
because it suggests that you can that
has properties that you can query that
you can use it to connect and disconnect
so it does things yeah but if we just
call that relational database it I think
you would have the same expectation my
question is this at the time when we
also can do writing as well as reading
how will this look largely the same but
so what's the operation that actually
causes the transaction to happen
there'll be some kind of database that
we need something like so there are two
possibilities so right now if we're
going to expose it through the entity
framework the entry framework has
l-value mutation and the Rob is that
what l-value mutation okay so you can
say yeah and the problem is with that is
that if you do it very procedural be
like that then you end up doing fridge
for each shell value mutation and you
can do it there's action which is really
really bad so we don't need something
like a block construct that which will
wrap around all these creations or a
commit command which would say okay yeah
but so I think transactions are also in
many cases lexical so that once we use
any D functions if we are going to use
updates through any D functions then
that can also be a lexical construct
that wraps things in transactions it's
not always have to has to be a dynamic
thing like a block I would even think
it's more lexical anyway because we are
going to compile it to SQL rankings but
though I have to say that I am really
leaning towards calling this relational
database not relational database object
because I think by the time you have a
thing that does commits you're going to
want relational database commit and
things like this
yeah but the question is what we expose
that through for which interface right
now we're exposing these three entities
and they don't have this kind of notion
you have a single resolver called entity
value and then you have mutations so so
if we are not going to extend the
entities with some new constructs then
what we can do is to use entity well new
resolver also to do commit something
like that what do you mean I don't
understand how we'd use that resolver to
do that because that resolver is just
returning values yes it's also executing
the query and when you are if you are
that's a total hack that's a total hack
we're not going to use entity value
that's that ostensibly gets out values
in order to do a database right when you
when you when you when you write to a
database you typically get back results
which are at the very least the number
of affected rows and it's way too much
of a hack to use entity value to do
writes well on the other hand if we use
it use entity value I mean right now we
are using increasingly until value on
the L L value from so when you write
when you write entity open square
bracket property equals something oh yes
for instance eval you
that's just so on the Left inaudible you
I don't have a problem with being an L
value
my problem is Leonids idea that it's a
symbolic writing command that then is
actually resolved and executed because
it so happens to be wrapped in entity
value actually see the big problem with
that when we're going to write what you
really have to mean is the the the the
Select to update so in that case you
cannot have the usual evaluation if
user value the usual evaluation
semantics that first you evaluate the
right inside and lessons so that's wrong
and know okay I understand
I suspect what we're gonna end up with
is a symbolic specification of the
transaction and then a thing that says
do it and yeah yeah no but I mean the
question is if the query language is all
written entities they would have
something that is like yeah what we
don't have is you know right now there's
an l-value concept of blah blah blah
equals blah blah blah okay we need to
cross this bridge later it's not the
issue for right now
absolutely my point for right now is I
think we should call this thing
relational database not relational
database object
because this is the representation of
the relational date I mean so what is
its real function so we got a database
connection it's pretty weird frankly
we've got a database connection and okay
so theta based connection it's just like
file in URL it's a completely lazy
concept yeah so what does this do no no
absolutely not when you when you call
relational database object or if you
want to try it in the SQL database
object around the database connection it
will connect and it will extract all the
metadata we need a place to store all
that metadata which is the schema yeah
something that you want to do at every
connection time it's it can be something
that takes up to 15 minutes if to the
business large and far away so okay I'm
gonna make several suggestions here okay
I think we should consider renaming
database connection okay I think we
should consider calling it because it
isn't really a connection it's not an
active connection maybe we call it
database reference or something or
database location it's not it's not
quite what he just said it's not quite
true because internally it actually
points to an active connection
okay so the claim that's lazy is not
correct
authentication think wait wait a minute
if I give authentication at what point
does it tell me if the database needs
authentication at what point does it pop
the password dialog
how you give password immediately to
this to create this object okay
wait-wait-wait-wait-wait
is database connection lazy or not if it
is lazy then it's not gonna pop password
until you do until you ask to create the
relational database
it's never gonna pop a password because
we don't have asked for dialog mutated
so you just have to put the password in
it but let me rephrase your question if
you put the wrong password in the
database connection when is it gonna
complain that the password is wrong it's
not when you evaluate that of this
connection it's when you actually call
for example when you actually make work
so either without wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute no it'll do it when
you ask for relational database when you
create the relational yeah first that
but imagine that you create the entity
store and then the password gets changed
but the administrator you can use the
relational database object but then when
you try to okay so I'm gonna argue that
the correct thing that this is wrong
that we're confusing ourselves by
calling this database connection it is
not a connection it is simply a
reference to a database
and that then this here
I'm not sure that's the right name
either but this here I mean I think it
would be more sensible if it said
something like relational database of
database reference or database location
or something
and that then returns a relational
database that contains the schema
metadata and then to use this you say
entity store of that
I would
my proposal I'm not completely set on
these names but that's what I think we
should something like this is what I
think we should do
I just don't think this is a connection
it's not an active connection it
confuses things to make the claim that
it is because for example if you have a
service connect let's say I do service
connect right don't I get then I get a
service object out of that maybe we're
gonna call this rapper then database
settings which rapper instead of
database reference it's not settings
it's what is it it's a it's a pointer to
a database no it's not it tells you look
it's a symbolic thing just like file
what what is the thing now you're just
gonna tell me it's called database but I
don't want to use up that name for this
sorry what is the question again okay
what is this thing okay so this thing is
merely a wrapper that contains I mean is
it perhaps something more like database
object well it can contain okay not only
did the the connection about the hosts
of us for the wort and so on but in
general it could contain also database
specific settings like you can start the
connection with some extra settings so
again I'm sorry
tell me again what is it in this outer
wrapper in this relational database
thing that isn't in the inner wrapper
it's that the inner wrapper is merely a
symbolic representation of where the
database is correct but it has not yet
connected to it is that right
yeah actually I feel that these
references probably isn't smooth I mean
it is like just a file reference or a
URL it's the location of days it's the
password it's it's not nothing more than
that
right so in principle you could call
relational database directly on a file
name without using this database
reference thing you can you fire
I just don't particularly like reference
because we also need a place because
it's not it's not really just our
reference there are also some
connections flag that we want to
document especially like when we will do
like transaction and stuff so there are
a lot of flags that you can set that
connection and I think this is the place
where those flags should leave well okay
so what would what would you call it I
mean it's yeah I was saying that are
basic things no because it's not just
the settings it's the database this this
symbolic object represents a reference
to this database it does not represent
merely the settings of the database it
represents a reference to the database
I think I recover I think that this
stuff that you're saying like specific
settings if you think about it
username and password are settings but
they are part of can be part of a URL as
well and so and URL is a reference so I
think it's fine do you think it's the
right name or do you think it should be
location or something or no I think I
think reference is fine it's more than
just a location and many keys you can
avoid using it is just convenient
because it's hard like if you don't use
it then you have to use URL magic
strings which are just just a hack in
this case you can put a nice Association
inside with host goes to port goes to
blah blah all right so let's try and
write the documentation for this and see
if it works okay database reference a
yeah can you can you start by copying
the what already exists for dummies
connection because it just know I will
obviously I'm writing a guide page first
okay then I will copy over that okay um
and by the way I think that the end of
what you're doing here with entity store
looks pretty good to me okay I haven't
looked at the details of these last few
usage cases but I mean Tony can control
any please comment on this yes
the only question I had was if you what
maybe have in the single argument case
you know where we use the relational
database object directly if the first
argument should be something like all or
if you just keep it I think as a
courtesy we can just have it like this
but I agree that that should be the
default should be all that yeah um okay
on our live stream Ethan is suggesting
the name database metadata but I don't
think that's quite right it's not just
the metadata it's the it represents here
let's try and write what it says
representation of
a reference to an external SQL database
with authentication etc
um
maybe you can write the password and
okay okay now the next thing here would
be um
okay the next thing would just be
[Music]
you
relational database okay so this is
symbolic representation of a relational
database actually we only need to say
just an external database I'm symbolic
representation of a relational database
with schema is that right
of relation of relational database and
its schema I think that's about right I
like Indian which normally we had the
word object when is something that is
constructed by another function right so
like URL a synchronous something is
relating a synchronous object and your
job this is a South Korean actor yeah if
we are changing that it might be fine
was just hitting it about this business
okay so the next thing is registering
database content okay symbolic
representation of an entity store
uhh
representing database tables or
something how can we say that symbolic
representation of database tables
through an entity store
maybe ng to store types because if you
represent tables they're represented as
types yeah I understand but I mean so
what should we say for the whole thing
though the whole thing when we say
entity store what would you use entity
no
then just say database through the
energy store okay but the problem was
this as the if we only select few tables
we can still construct an entity store
and that will represent the part of a
database is fine
symbolic representation of database
tables through an entity store
about that representation of database
this sounds a bit ambiguous I mean I
think a database is fine because if you
really want to be pedantic you can even
not register tables but just register
basically a constructor query so you can
you can just register an entity class an
increasing tendency class where you're
filtering okay it's all right entity
register okay
register entities corresponding to a
table that right no you register store
in style
what does entity register do takes an
ante store and registers all the
entities all all the tables sorry all
the types that are in there empty store
okay so at this point okay
register entities from an entity so they
can be referenced I wouldn't say a
register entities what would you say is
a register entity types yes okay yes
that makes sense
so they can be referenced directly Sofer
yeah okay so that we got those two
utility pieces okay okay all right so
now these are our functions is this all
our functions or do we have more these
are all for now okay
okay so entity class
representation of a table a virtual
table is that right
yeah that right a single entity in the
database
yeah oh the base you have rose so if you
want to use database language you should
say a single row when they'll enter teh
corresponding to a row in a database
yeah I think that's better because
rather than because the row is the data
and the entity is lazy reference - yeah
that's correct
it also contains certain things that
rows do not cite shares in the worst
keys so are you happy with this
description yeah yep
technically a role in that table yeah so
in a database table very good okay all
right do we do we want to have an
overall description here let's say um
I don't know what how we can't describe
that okay let's keep going I wonder
where that I wonder whether entity class
should be moved with the other filtered
empty class or Atlanta class etc because
since it can be used implicitly
you know with the with rule and second
argument then we have nothing up at the
top I mean samosa and also in some sense
the ones that are below they represent
transforms while this thing represents
the sort of a ingredient like the
constituent from which you build oh okay
let's put it this way then and the gas
should be in both places one is okay all
right okay okay yeah okay extract a
value from an entity or entity class is
that right or is that not general enough
um extract a value from well since we
are nation since we're not how
discussing this in the database context
it should be useful to also mention that
this actually execute query on the
database fine um perform data perform
database queries to extract a value to
exact values I think that in in general
you you want to use it to extract more
than one form of database query well
extract values by performing a database
query
you
okay get a list of entities from from
from a database query okay what are
these here know whether is this every
function except for this merged one
which we don't like the name of
yeah okay all right entity property
um symbolic representation what is what
is the database term for this column
okay
symbolic representation of an entity
property or strictly speaking column
corresponding to a column name
um
you
symbolic representation
you
symbolic what's the right way to say
that
um of an entity property but there is a
problem with this because we may in the
future end up with entity properties
which will correspond to more than one
column in a database okay and so this
really corresponds to a field or well
and property of entity that's well
that's what it says right I mean it's
it's a yes symbolic representation
something like that again act by the
database
what is this thing what is the right
description for this thing symbolic
representation of a name by the way Carl
on our live students pointing out that
this description is lousy get a list of
entities from a database query um you
know extract values should we say by
implicitly performing a database query
to make it clear you don't have to do it
I think it makes it yeah I think it
makes it pretty clear that any value is
the subject here so you don't do it it
does it would be confusing okay
all right okay get a list of values get
a list of entities by performing a
database query okay so right entity
property again what should that be well
maybe what we can see is that so what
what loriel is saying is that maybe we
should use say that the column might be
virtual instead of calling field okay
fine but just tell me what this is this
is a um entity property corresponding to
what are you sending me you sending me
something no I think it was India it was
for Andrea I just don't like to run my
mistake um okay okay so this is symbolic
representation of a property of a
property
or something like effectively column
name
well the other thing we would do is
instead of using column negatives
attribute which is algebra version it's
so obscure doesn't that solve the
problem that might not or typically
column name typically is but yeah okay
that will be less obscure for people um
okay
entity function
so this is pure function well function
of pure function of entities of entities
with a body that can be executed in the
database basically I would say instead
of seeing pure function entities because
there is one exception to that rule
always entity can we see something there
is like a functional representation of
an expression on the database oh that's
much better or it can be a function like
cost binds to and it is no you then you
just blew it then you just want to the
color subtraction okay well my pure
function what were you saying
so in in in sequel to distinguish
between queries and expressions and
expressions are when you're performing
some or max total stuff like that it's
pure function representation of a
database expression no your thing yeah
well that might not be always correct in
the future although it's probably scroll
now then we can change it in the future
okay yeah it's through the
represent the sub-query as well yes so
expressionist or or an entity what in
principle could represent an entity if
the result value is an entity yeah but
that's okay it's still an expression
we're just going here keep going here
okay
so filter the entity class I think it
would be important to see sub-query not
query okay so first of all is this
ordering reasonable well okay so entity
class okay so these are what what is the
heading for these things these are
transformations on entity classes
basically except maybe for the extended
entity class well run extra classes
Tony's point is that how about symbolic
operations on entity classes suggesting
they don't happen immediately
oh the problem the reason why
transformations were better is that they
tell you explicitly that the result
value is also an entity class all
operations can result in anything
okay this is like the database page
can't we just tell that those are a way
to write a query
yeah but you have to tell at least
briefly what they return if you can and
they all return other entity classes
yeah let's say that this is a
constructed map to a query to an SQL
query well you put I would prefer
operations here because I think the fact
that it says symbolic suggests that you
know first of all it suggests it's not
going to happen immediately let's try
and write the documentation here okay
entity class filtered by a criterion by
is it always an entity function
now it can be a property if it's boolean
okay what about symbolic query on entity
glasses
no it's income principle because query
you have to know you know what a
database is yes this page yes but but
people will be able to use this page
without knowing SQL
I hope sure but that still is an
aberration of quitting sees when you say
query most people are gonna think the
query happens immediately
but I think so soon what's the algebraic
term homomorphism and you know going
from a space to the same space yeah I
think that this is something that
transformation conveys better that you
know it's something that goes from the
space of extra classes to the space of
NC classes okay
representations of
about that
yep okay Anthony class filter by a
criterion entity class
sorted by a what by a function
it's either a property or function more
commonly a property I would say or more
it can also be sorted by several
properties at the same time then the
function um no it's not a function but
in any way it does make properties or
function which we say by properties or a
function it can also be making functions
or moves there off yeah okay sampled
entity class how do we describe that
what is the stance that what what is the
sample is it random or the problem is no
it's it's not random but it's unless you
sort it just before there is no
guarantee that it comes out in any
particular order that's a problem we
can't guarantee that it's random we
can't guarantee that okay
sample of entities from an entity class
right
except this may sound as if this would
be a list when it is well is also in the
class but these are transformations are
in three classes it says there in the
heading and to the class is this formed
from well okay entity class formed by
formed by sampling by sampling a number
of entities yeah sounds good okay
extended entity class so this is
basically the same entity class with one
and more properties handed this white
one is has the
slanter information on the entry glass
itself reading if I consider that to be
sort of a separate thing as you said
maybe let's put it at the bottom I mean
it's not the only one that adds
properties okay what what what's this
one so aggregate identity it agreed ante
class performs aggregations on on the
entities of the class possibly grouping
by result what I would start forms a new
entity class creates a new entity class
formed from aggregations performed over
the original one good it has to fit in
one line formed by aggregating entities
yeah that kind of subsumes that you
might want to group as well first since
it's fine
formed by aggregation how do you
aggregate them well if you don't provide
the third arguments you aggravate them
all together in one big rope I said if
you group by then you might get multiple
rows ok fine ok merged entity class now
we want to rename this what are our
possible names for this join the cross
entity class which I hate and then
you'll say line at some combining
clauses you can bind where did two other
options now all you have their property
combined is pretty descriptive but it's
a long name
I'm post I'm sorry say the gun compost I
don't think so it's like it's very
composed it's not all over the place
it's beautifully turned out um tell me
again what this does i I'm I'm horrified
that you have to explain it so many
times it takes two entity classes
yeah and for each of them it takes pairs
of entities and uh if they match
together it forms from each pair of
entity and you entity containing
properties of those two entities so it's
basically a filter mount of altered
product yes that's probably okay but one
of the things that's interesting about
it is that it is it takes two entity
classes and only a small fraction
potentially of the elements of those two
entity classes make it into this join
right not always because you can have
for example cross join that will be the
full outer product so it all depends on
the condition that you supply what about
what about simply the name joined entity
class or what if we want to do an actual
join in the Wolfram language sense that
is but but we can't do this in this
context anyway if you have two entity
classes that are have the same schema
effectively you could in principle join
them together how would you know you now
you can it's it's in civil school Union
Union all as opposed to Union which
removes the duplicates that that is
really what joined us in the Wolfram
language yeah so he so color you would
prefer to reroute to keep this name for
when we sub start supporting you know
yeah yeah absolutely
I think it's it's not very difficult to
support all this let's say vertical
things like Union intersection
yeah sure it's it's not it's not hard so
Union all would become join dance class
and Union will become unions antique
locks I guess or maybe delete duplicate
it because it's it doesn't sort I'm
right I mean it's a little crazy to be
using all of these functions I mean how
many how far do we go you know there are
not so many of them still on there are
just a few and we already like you can
actually think there are actually very
few of them look there are only five and
you give they give you almost all the
power of SQL so you know if you remember
we talked about this at some point
whether we would should have something
which is like a general Parader that
then takes over from language function
that's it's the equivalent the problem
is that this gives too much of the idea
like in data set that you can do
absolutely everything and then and then
when you when we cover just two percent
of the operations that Wolfram language
can do wouldn't you will be disappointed
you don't understand and also I don't
know to what extent you are willing to
look at other examples out there but in
most or RMS or other languages such as
even for example link which is Li and Q
the language integrated query in the
c-sharp platform they prefer always to
use separate primitives for pretty
similar set of primitives that we are
introducing here so I mean there are
many presidents of doing this kind of
design in different platforms languages
yeah it's just I I just hope people are
gonna be able to understand all this
stuff
um let's by the way
Carl on the live stream is asking what
the difference between merged entity
class an extended entity class is and
the difference is that merged entity
class can change the number of entities
because it's performing effectively a
Cartesian product between 20 classes an
extent this is only adding properties
piecemeal so it cannot change the
cardinality of the entity class okay so
you know one thing is this is look this
is the first this is the only one of
these that is not unary that operates on
multiple entity classes right yeah again
okay I understand okay so the words that
we have are joined we don't want to use
it because we because it's conflicting
with join MERS were worried it's
conflicting with our merge operation
combined we think it isn't explicit
enough
you
what about product product and
class hmm oh boy but it's not always a
product it's it might be confusing
although in some sense it is and there's
a filtered out of product yes yes it is
except that it's filtered in a very
specific way it's filtered by a property
well that's a short term in the most
general form it's it's filtered by my
predicate but you want to do the dry
personally given that description
I say combined entity class makes more
sense
you
let's let's see what happens if we write
that okay see and I think that combined
Kanna has the same problem as joint like
you're not conveying the fact that your
combined horizontally and not vertically
you know there is not like an entity
group or some sort well let's see
but there is an AR concept to express it
in the name so entity class
formed by combining
classes with corresponding properties no
not very good
you
about augmented energy loss okay the
question is what's augmented what's
extended yeah yeah I think it's largely
the same I think we can I think we have
to give some word that reflects the fact
that there's more than one entity class
that's being you know that's being
operated on here product does that no it
only does that because you're thinking
of it as a mathematical product if you
just see the word product to most people
you know it means something bizarrely
and utterly different plus our own
product function is a product as in you
know capital PI type product hmm
which is not exactly x is what we would
call maybe how to exit last
I'm looking at tum ah
I mean blended entity class or is that
too weird
to me what comes out of a blender yeah
it assumes somehow some randomness or
some kind of linked linked entity closed
mixed entity closed mixed as better but
probably by this probably still better
Karlis talking about dishwashers and
yeah I agree
um all right combined entity class
[Music]
but by combining entities with
corresponding properties
I would say just just see cool and the
most general way of saying it is like
and because formed by combining the
properties of 20 classes and then don't
say anything about the predicate or say
something about predicate can you know
my listen to it once no no this makes it
a little confusing in terms of the fact
that you combine fairer entity not per
class I don't know how how implicit is
it I mean how how it clear it is from
this description that this is not like
that you basically have to do it entity
by entity about something like this look
this is just a short description let's
let's keep going and see whether we can
write a
I think that's not totally terrible they
said no it's not okay
let's then do the rename here okay we've
got a couple of renames to do and
unfortunately I'm gonna run out of time
again but I think we made progress sir
because I think we've got the final
names here which is really good um we've
still got work to do and I want to look
at the documentation fans who store but
let's do the renames that we have to do
okay so merged entity clasts becomes
combined entity class
you know um so is it under who's here
peering yes could you could you report
this thing that this has gotten just
unbelievably slow typing in this some
unless I don't use a nice I shouldn't
yeah this starts when thing is super
cool but it's got but got an incredibly
slow at this point that's a thing for
foot Brian I think and personally I'd be
perfectly happy just to type the name
right and just say matches and then this
could be a pull down that could be used
for pure cuteness value um
you
you
you
oh that's totally confused there okay um
all right so the other things we want to
change our database connection
you
you
becomes database reference
you
you
you
and what was the thing that we called
this before relational database what's
now relational database was database in
a relational database object is you've
already excised SQL database object okay
SW SH our livestream asks about group
as a name similar to
dataframe group by method for for our
combined thing no I think for aggregated
but I the the thing is that we before
that we had grouped and aggregated and
there were different things one with
three argument one were two since
grouping is optional and published
nautical group is that an official name
SQLite database
absolve them but I mean is that is that
a multi brand name or is that just the
name of a particular brand it's a very
particular brand it's just a file based
database very specific produced by a
single company he's recovering yes so I
think we should just say to a local file
based SQL database and not decide
whether it's that particular kind I
don't think this is correct John why
because because it's very specifically
always doing this through the SQLite
database but it's always dot SQLite it
depends on the file name if there was
some other thing that got developed
there was another local file based SQL
database then right I mean so far SQLite
is the only one that has files with
report and also SQLite is the most
widely used database in the world okay
fine there's nothing wrong with that
yeah there's nothing wrong with this
statement though represents a remote SQL
database right yeah maybe we can just
both the more specific details to detail
section yeah yeah that's fine okay
okay so but now this can have options
right it can have authentication options
correct
options it takes on Association as the
first argument also I mean it if you
provide that maybe I should add a third
you to messenger yes yes but yeah I mean
usually you type just URL and then yeah
remember I'm gonna time exit it unpacks
it into an association but yeah we can
talk about the association okay whatever
it is I don't know what your association
is there um okay you'll document that
but but you're saying that this and by
the way that that formatting is that
looks horrible
yeah I know I don't know how to make it
look better you have to us that's right
improbably has to use the formula font
or whatever it's called and yeah it's
the literal font yeah shoot I'm gonna
have to go in just a moment here so so
let me just look at some we'll have to
continue this I'm sorry we did make good
progress today
um
yeah hopefully we can fit this in um
within the next two days but I think we
made good progress I think you're you're
good to go to finish the implementation
here I'm not totally long finished by
from bytes and renaming functions yeah
sure that Big Sur 22nd well good that's
all good I do not like the term back-end
I mean if this is the SQL dialect then
say that the name of the database that
definition
I mean unfortunately the back end is
more precise than the dialect I also be
ancient Muhammad on our live stream asks
of Allah speed improvement using
database integration of a database link
absolutely no it is absolutely not the
same technology it is a new technology
but I'm sorry to say that in the first
version there will be no speeding
parameter at all right because yes
that's absolutely right because we were
focusing on Korea generation and in
terms of the in fact database link is
pretty pretty fast
apart from the case when you are
executing a fairly small query multiple
times so if you are executing anything
that takes any real does any real work
and the database and they the base link
is pretty fast because it's using
nothing I mean it using GA link and so
format link behind the scenes to
transfer the and it's using Java so so
we will improve and performance later
but for Russian one we were not
specifically focusing on performance I
mean is that for all seers workloads the
bottleneck is database so you're not
gonna be waiting a long time for data to
come back right with respect to database
reference Karl our live stream is
talking about indirectly referenced
credentials and the authentication you
know I really think we need to support
authentication properly because it has
really pretty good technology for you
know dealing with authentication
dialogues and so on so this username and
password stuff you should be able to
feed that in again
let's not solve that right now but URL
has an authentication option I think you
should be able to use that to put this
stuff in there because that means that
you can then use all the stuff for
masking the the credentials and it's in
a notebook etc etc by making sense so
you're not just doing that the
horrendous thing
the people using databases so often do
which is to burn plaintext passwords and
de scripts and so on am I making sense
yeah we'll look into that I'm not sure
we have the time to properly integrate
stuff like education dialogue for
version 12 really you do because it
because you don't have another thing to
do it doesn't it
authentication dialog just returns an
association see all you have to do is
it's okay you will be able to do this
just just learn from the URL people how
the authentication option works okay and
it will even do better than that it will
integrate properly with keychains and
everything and people will not have to
type their database passwords in plain
text which I just think is the most
horrendous ridiculous security issue
that I've seen way to me was the main
person we have to interface with
Fahim would know about it and Brad
Ashley would know about it okay okay
all right I really need to go
unfortunately is that just for one
second I mean look at this um are you
confident of this setup here I mean is
this does this correspond what an earth
is all of this stuff
Wow did Tony sign off on
stuff
so I see the first time the answer is no
no no wait wait wait you see the first
time in the documentation yes yes okay
all right to be continued but I'm gonna
assume that Tony will have gone through
this and I mean
yes I agree with the design of
specifying tables and properties okay
while in this actual thing up here
isn't this the analog of our data up
here all of this stuff down here no not
really because it's it's like a
shorthand that then gets expanded to
data yeah I understand I'm just talking
about the structure of the documentation
whether we put all of that level of
detail up in that usage section or
whether we just say down here I don't
think we should put that whole level of
detail up there I think we should
shuffle around yeah I mean I would put
less detail there I would just say type
one arrow
you know source one or something here
and leave that that line as the end of
it and then put all the detail about
what that source can be down below um
okay terrific all right we'll okay to
wrap it up here and to be continued
thanks you guys and thanks to people on
the livestream
I will push all this documentation back
into the repository um okay see y'all
soon why thank you